THAT DOES THE DIRTY WORK, NUMBER
17, P.J. TUCKER.
ZORA: YOU GOOD?
P.J.: YEAH, I'M GOOD.
ZORA: Y'ALL, P.J. NEEDS A
MINUTE.
YOU SAID THIS GROUP WAS FULL OF
SOME DOGS.
YOU SAID THEY WERE FULL OF SOME
DOGS.
HOW DID THEY DISPLAY THAT ON
THIS CHAMPIONSHIP RUN?
P.J.: YOU KNOW, IT'S CRAZY.
I CAME HERE, THEY WERE LIKE YO,
YOU'VE GOT A LIKE, BE THE DOG.
AND I'M LIKE, MAN, WE'VE GOT
DOGS.
LIKE, I GOT HERE LIKE, WE'VE
ALREADY GOT DOGS.
THEY JUST DON'T KNOW HOW TO BE
DOGS.
AND WE ARE GOING TO BE DOGS.
DOGS IS CRAZY.
WE'VE GOT DOGS, YOU HEAR ME?
MILWAUKEE, WE DOGS!
ZORA: YOU WERE EMOTIONAL AS THE
BUZZER SOUNDED ON TUESDAY.
AND YOU TALKED ABOUT ALL THE
TRIALS AND TRIBULATIONS THAT
HAVE LED YOU TO THIS POINT.
HOW SWEET IS THE END, MY FRIEND?
P.J.: YOU SEE ALL THESE -- WHAT?
YOU CAN'T MAKE THIS UP, MAN.
THESE DUDES, THIS ORGANIZATION,
WHAT WE PUT TOGETHER, YOU CAN'T
MAKE THIS UP.
NOTHING MATTERS EXCEPT WHAT
GOING ON RIGHT HERE, RIGHT NOW!
THAT'S ALL THAT MATTERS!
THEY CAN SAY WHAT THEY WANT.
BUT THEY GOT TO SAY WE CHAMPS.
ZORA: AAYYY.
ONE MORE SWIG FOR THE CROWD?
P.J.: ONE?
ZORA: [LAUGHTER]
[CHEERING]
ZORA: P.J. TUCKE